l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
c'est ce que l'on peut appeler le
dinosaure des projets
politico-économique dans l'ouest voilà
plus de quarante ans que l'idée de
construire une nouvelle plate forme
aéroportuaire près de nantes est née au
début tout va vite en 1967 on parle pour
la première fois d'installer cette
structure à notre dame des landes
cinq ans plus tard le projet est lancé
et en 1974 une zone d'aménagement
différé est créé elle réserve 1225
hectares de terrain en prévision des
travaux
au départ on fait dit on subissait
c'est à dire que qui fait pas fait pour
beaucoup de gens disent même qu'ils
étaient contre on peut par contre c'est
ce que tout le monde leur répondais et
les gens avaient avaient peur de 2,2
prononcés contre ce projet d'aéroport
ensuite jusqu'au milieu des années 90 le
projet tombe aux oubliettes et le
transport aérien ne se développe pas
comme prévu alors qu'en 1972 on tablait
sur 5 à 9 millions de passagers à nantes
pour l'an 2000 en 2001 on atteignait
seulement la barre des 2 millions de
passagers annuels
du coup lorsque le gouvernement annonce
la reprise du projet il y a 6 ans
certains restent sceptiques
bon c'est vrai que dossiers dorment et
puis maintenant ça se réveille à coup on
sépare est-ce que c'est fait ce que j'ai
pas fai s'est peut-être jouée d'avancé
tout est joué d'avancé ce qui s'est dit
pendant le débat public de 2003 mais
alors que l' enquête d'utilité publique
va commencer les opposants au projet ne
désarment pas ils espèrent un nouveau
changement de cap dans ce dossier où le
temps joue en leur faveur et du temps il
leur en reste
l'ouverture de l'aéroport est prévu dans
le meilleur des cas entre 2013 et 2015